[Music]
Yes, this one is Ppooppoosher,
and the reason I chose this snack is actually that the snacks I
liked when I was a kid were actually the kind of snacks that are
consistently popular even now.
But I
don't eat this because I just break it down a lot. I just sprinkle it once,
twice, three times
.  Mix it, just
eat it on top. If
you do this, the powder will
spread all over the inside
.
I sold it.
I never saw this when I was young. There are a
lot of coins thrown away under the ladder.
I found a jungle gym and
caught a lot of these.
[Music]
I
brought these myself. This is a
snack I bought this time from Japan.
Grape flavor is the most recommended
. I have it here, so
I can't really do it like this.
Butlike this,
hello,
I'm Sunah.
Even if I like Pizza, I ca
n't eat pizza because it's too big
.
But
I feel like I'm eating pizza to the fullest
. That's why I liked it.
So now that I'm eating it,
I like the sweets and this very delicious chocolate. I
really like it. Hello, I'm
Jiwoo.  One has a short one that looks like this
, and one has
a star candy.
Because there was a man who got scolded for
not eating vegetables like that when I was young
Me, I
still don't eat
them
.
Skittles
I really like it in April
I was really young Elementary school
student I ate a lot since I was really young But there was powder back then There
was sour powder in Seoul, so when I was young
I
ate it without thinking and my tongue bled But still, it was delicious so I kept eating it  I have such a
memory, so I brought this this
time. Every time I go to the mart
, since I was a kid, I just unconditionally
went to the chocolate cluster and picked it unconditionally
.
I separated it,
something, so at first I melted it and ate it,
but later
I think I chew it
.
I say it often. I
think that's really good.
Hello, this is
Chaeyoung. I chose the
banana kick.
When I was younger
,
I did
n't eat too many snacks.  It
was okay and it was rice,
but the only thing I went to buy snacks
then was the banana kick. I
don't know why I didn't like it, but I liked
banana milk and banana kicks.
Hello
[Music]
When I was young, I really didn't eat a lot of snacks, and I do
n't have them in
Korea. So, I
usually like
shrimp snacks or seafood snacks,
so I really enjoyed these
. The members ate a lot of these together
.
I want to go like this. You know what
it is. It's crispy and has a bit of a shrimp taste. It's a crispy
cookie
. It's not too salty,
so it's addictive.